ちょっとだけよろしいですか
マッチュラージャンという言葉はヤマという言葉と同じ意味に捉えていいんですか
マーラも大体同じ意味
矢に五つの花がついているというのは
どんな風に花がついてるんですか？前の方に矢じり
見たことはないんです
どうでもいい それシンハだから
キーピ見たことありますか？ギリシャのキーピでも矢も花でできてますよ
それでバカな人はこの花が尻尾の方に尾っぽの方についてるんだよとかね
こんなのはどうでもいいでしょうに
嘘だから とにかく人間の妄想だから
あとあの群で心のことを言ってるという話だったんですけども
一九二九がですね 体のことを言ってて
群で心のことを言ってるということで
それで一九のカーヤをですね
カーヤンをチッタンに置き換える
そういう単純なことでもよろしいんでしょうか
心は泡の如く 陽炎のようなものだというふうに置き換えても
それはそれでよろしいでしょうか
心も陽炎に例えたところは別なところではありますけどね
こちらでは文法的には一行と二行は一つつなげてますから
やっぱり体に入ってますね
ペーヌパマンマリチダンマンという 2つも
マリチダンマン心にするならば
この体格というかね あれ抜けてますでしょ
主格はね 主格なしに文章は語れませんだからね
アビサンブダノーを四角に取れませんです
だから何をアビサンブダノーするんでしょうかね
変わるんでしょ 結局は
対角線  チッタン入れたければこれは入れなくちゃいけないんです
抜かすことはできない
たとえ C であろうとも
そういう意味じゃなくてですね
三句で心のことを言ってるというのを
三句ってどういう意味？ 三行目
そこをその一行目二行目を縮めて三行目にしてるというふうに理解してですね
一行目のカーヤンをチッタンというふうにして
その長い文章を三行目で短くしてるという
一行目のカーヤンはわざとチッタンにするの
一行目二行目はそのままあるわけです
で それとそれをチッタンに置き換えた文章をもう一回繰り返すんですけども
カーヤンもチッタンもその泡の泡のようなものであり
陽炎のようなものであるということをですね
同じように言っていいのかどうかということを問いたかっただけなんですけど
そこまで苦労するっていいんだよ
じゃあ直せますか？その文は
ちょっと試しに直して見せてくれるんだったら考えてあげますけど
こういうの針一本も刺せないぐらい完璧なんですけど
こういうブッダの言葉っていうのはね
そこはまず前提として覚えて説明すると
ブッダの考え方からは逸れないんですよ
ちょっといろいろ単語を入れたり付け加えたりしちゃうと危なくてわからなくなく
どこまで脱線するかわからないんですね
一応基本的にはお釈迦様がこの針一本も刺せるぐらい穴は置いておかないんです
そんなに完璧に語れる能力はたった一人ブッダしか世の中では存在しない
そこは我々の世界ではしっかりその通りだというふうにしているんです
テーラワーダ 特にテーラワーダ宗派の場合はね
だからほんのちょっとこの書き打ち打ち写したりするんだからね
時々このなまりに乗ってちょっと単語を変えたりする
それですごく苦労するんですよ
文法的に直しちゃえばいいかっていうこと
これもできなくて 例えばこの経典なんかね
もうだってあのインターネットのミャンマーの版見ても
括弧の中でいろんな言葉書いてるでしょ
同じ単語のミャンマーでこれで
スリランカでこれで タイでこれやとかね
捨てちゃえばいいんだ
捨てられないんですね
このバリアントレディスというものはね
この中でもたくさんいろいろあると思いますけど
例えばこの注釈書ではものすごいたくさんレディンスは入れてますよ
それはもうやっぱり原本はね
そのまま守らなくちゃいけないし
でも私たちは喋ったりすると訛りが入ったり
訛ったりする時もありますし
それで書き写す時は知らないうちに訛り
かえてkがgになったりとかね
なっちゃうし iの上に棒引か引かなくちゃいけないところは棒が落ちたりついたりするし
これでどうしようかというね
どうすることもできないんだから
まあ全部残しておくんです
だからブッダの言葉っていうのは完璧で
もうどうにもならん 針一歩も入らないということにして
人にちょっと変わったものは人が変えたものやと
ということにする 一応研究のやり方というやり方ですよ
パーリ研究研究の場合でも
わざと変えることはできない
で 言ってることにももう何か微妙なポイントはないわけでもないんだけど
なんで心っていう言葉ははっきり出てこないのかというね
ポイントはあるんで だからはっきり出てこないんだから
注釈書は意味意味を取ってないんですね
注釈書を読んでみたんですけど
注釈書の方がなんか別なことを言ってるんです
この三界に対して執着しないでくださいと
パプッパカーニっていうのはそういう意味だと
どうやってそんな風に読めるのかっていうことは言われ言ってないんですね
しかし 文学的に見ると
もうパプッパカといえばもう嫌なことで
もう花がついている矢といえばもうキューピッドなんですね
キューピッドはこちら悪魔にしていますけど
本当はもう人の心に欲を作る人でしょ
あの恋の天使でしょ インドでも同じなんですね
この何とかでした アナンガと言うんですよ
キューピッドの名前 サンスクリット語で
アナンガが誰か男と女に矢を刺しちゃうと
お互いは恋に落ちちゃうんですね
それはもうどうにもならん
人は死ぬんじゃないんだから
これは矢じゃない やっぱり花なんですね
だから これで私が引っかかったところは花が五つだからね
これ心ということは明らかですよ
これ心の病だからね 恋っていうのは肉体の病じゃないんだから
だからそこで心のからくりを言いたくて
すごい例えを入れちゃったんです
どうせあの川とかね 陽炎というのは自然界にあるものでしょ
だから 詩を書く人は心に対しても
やっぱり何か自然界から使わなくちゃいけないんだけど
インド文学では自然界でなくてもいいんです
そういう神話をとってもいいんです
だからもう神話を例えにとるのは何のこともないんです
あなたはインドラのように強いんだよと言うと
わからないでしょう インドラのことをわからないんだからね
見たこともないんだけど
でも神話の世界では インドラは戦争の戦いの神で
もう負けず嫌いで どこへ行っても勝つ
だから 特に王を褒め称える時は
インドラのごとく勇気のある王様やと言うんです
だから 何々ごとくと言えばよく分かりやすく言ってほしいでしょうに
だから 泡のごとくと言えば分かりやすいでしょうに
人間経験するものでしょう
インドラのごとくと言ったら
インドラって誰？と でもインド文学ではそれでOKなんです
分からないと言ったら
あなたはもう勉強足らないと
だってあのエピソードで
このエピソードで このエピソードでそれ書いてるんではないかと
そういうエピソードから取ってるんだよと
だからサンスクリットの文学作品なんか解説したりする場合は
あらゆるエピソードを勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
それも決まってる詩の書き方なんです
だから その普通伝統的な書き方をとって
もうちょっとした神話のたとえを持ってくる
理解する人々はそれでパッと
これはもう心の話だと理解してもらわないと
だからわざと心ということを言わなくても大丈夫です
行目でそれが心の世界
それで仏教教理学的に言えば
ものすごい見事に心に体に対する執着を捨てて
次に心に対する執着を捨てて解脱を得られますよという教理学的な説明とぴったしあるんです
だから針一本も入らないんですよ
で 注釈書よりかなり私は変えて変わって説明はしたんです
この花は何なのかと 注釈書で全然書いてないんです
パプッパカサンカーターニテーブーマカーニワッターニと書いてます
パプッパカサンカーターニ
パプッパカという三界輪廻転生のね
いわゆる欲界 色界 無色界という三界という輪廻をやめなさいと
アリーヤマッゲーナチンディットワ
アリーヤマッガっていうのは八正道ですね
八正道でそれは切るんだよと
で 切り直すをビク 阿羅漢になったビクがマッチュラージ
使用には見えませんよという説明になっているんです
でもナーマルーパ ルーパに対する執着を捨てて
ナーマに対する執着を捨ててという順番だよということは言ってないんですね
[no sound]